now this dialogue by Roger is vitally
important to understanding everything
that's happened because it seems like
there's still some confusion within the
community I received this comment that
says people need to realize that the
Knight of black knives is implied to
have happened shortly after the Eldon
ring was shattered by the intro the
story trailer and Roger's dialogue now I
sort of understand getting confused by
the intro cinematic because it does
portray the Alden ring being shattered
into America Vanishing and then
showcasing the Knight of black knives
into the shattering War which is
different from the shattering of the
Elden ring however we did just watch the
story trailer and it's made clear by
Ronnie that it all started with death
being stolen Godwin being killed the
Elden ring being shattered America going
missing and then the war starting and we
just heard Roger say the same that the
death of Godwin was the Catalyst the
start of it all so at least we can be
sure about that